nothing wrong with a little snack so
overdue Doctor Who review and yes I am
admittedly gonna do something a little
bit weird and instead of jumping right
into the next episode I'm instead going
to talk about the mini episode bridging
series 1 and series 2 called born again
this was it was actually suggested by
commenter who asked whether or not I was
gonna do this an initially hadn't
planned to the kind of stopped and
thought about it and like I do kind of
want to talk about some of these mini
episodes now I already figured out what
ones I am and I'm not gonna do and I
mean I am NOT gonna cover every single
but like I think it was series 7 they
had like a prob
prologue sort of prequel little mini
thing before every episode I'm not doing
any of those I'm not gonna do like
attack of the grass music of the spheres
I'm not gonna do any of that basically I
like and this is a completely subjective
criteria anything that is a video that
if it were to be released today as like
part of the lead-up to Doctor Who as I
currently exist would I do a video on it
if the answer is yes then yeah I'm gonna
do one here and occupy a slot for that
plus it has the added bonus to bumping
the Christmas invasion to being in the
month of December which you know that's
nice so that brings us to born again our
first taste of David Tennant
as the doctor with Christopher Eccleston
now gone from the role and it's nice
there's a number of things I like about
this I mean it has the very thrown
together in one afternoon feel that
these things often tend to have because
it's completely confined to one set
there they have their using music that
they've used before there's actually
almost no sound effects um so you know
there's a little
things like that but for what it is it's
it's good and it's interesting and it's
I I do feel that the parting of the ways
explain what regeneration was well
enough that this sort of slightly more
detailed or more extended rather look at
what regeneration is wasn't necessary in
order to understand it so I think it
does work is kind of a bonus mini thing
and it does make sense that it is rose
even though the doctor explained it to
her before he changed is not immediately
just gonna start rolling with this right
off the bat she's gonna be super
skeptical especially given as she
herself says all the stuff she's already
seen like I know I already know the
other possibilities that this could be
I'm not just gonna take your word for it
and I like tenon sort of slowing down
and just sort of reaching into the past
and the history that they had together
and we got our little taste of his own
kind of manic nough sand and his a his
tendency to try and keep things light
you know we never stopped running he
remember hopping hopping for our lives
yeah which is a cute moment I also kind
of like as someone who has said
repeatedly that it drives me nuts that
it has now become a thing that the
TARDIS either blows up or crashes with
every single frickin regeneration even
if there's literally no reason for that
to happen I do like that in this even
though we go into the TARDIS crashing
and at the start of next episode it does
crash that I like the way it gets
justified here a heck of a lot better
than it has been in the other instances
in new whoo which is that the doctor as
a result of the regeneration and it
makes sense him saying this regeneration
seems like it's going a bit wrong
because the lead-up into this he
absorbed the time vortex
I think that's justifiable that this one
feasibly could have been a little wonky
and a little wrong but I like that the
reason that the TARDIS is crashing is
because he has these kind of manic
moments where he's like oh let's go
faster and he like in these moments
where he is not in proper control and
not completely in his right mind
whatever his new version of right mind
is because he doesn't even know at this
point is what leads him to take actions
that causes the TARDIS to crash as
opposed to the TARDIS suddenly starting
to crash because it's gonna crash or
blowing up because yeah I really am I'll
get the chances this goes on to
reiterate my real irritation at this at
this trend at this point but I do like
the way in which it is justified here
much better than than the other times I
think the single moment that I like best
out of this is rose asking him can you
change back and he says do you want me
to him without hesitation she goes yes
and he's just kind of not taken aback
not hurt but just kind of oh and you
know she can you know I can't and then
you know thinking of her do you want to
leave you know she says she doesn't
because well you know I I'm not what you
signed on for anymore
and I really I take a lot of
appreciation of that moment both the way
it's written out the the ideas is
playing off of and and the way it's it's
acted and betrayed that like that and
that happens about in the middle of this
five minute or so long thing and that is
kind of the heart of this little little
snippet for me because most of what's
the rest of it is is fine I mean it
gives you your first vibe of Tennant's
take on the doctor and it gives you you
know a taste of roses confusion but all
of this is gonna be done better in the
Christmas invasion and certainly in more
detail to get more room to breathe but I
really do love that moment of you know
can you change back No can you change
back do you want me to yes
well can you know it's I don't know that
that that part just meets me and like to
me that moment is what makes this
something worth watching as opposed to
be completely redundant in the wake of
you know what happened in the end of the
parting of ways and what will happen
during the Christmas invasion if it
wasn't for that moment this might be
just completely
superfluous but I really do love that
moment a lot I think largely it's the
reason to watch this and since it's only
about five minutes long you can get away
with watching it for only one moment so
am i overstate by overdoing it giving
these these little minisodes a complete
video ah maybe but you know what next
week will be in December which means
I'll get to talk about the Christmas
invasion when it is much more seasonal
and that won't happen again with the
other Christmas specials because of the
way the schedule will work out as I work
my way through and catch up to the day
of the doctor so born again have you
seen it what you think about it you know
it's free on YouTube you can see it if
you haven't before hope people might
have checked it out but I should you
know what I should have said you just go
and check it out before you watch that
yeah whatever whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
to do because his buttons and there's
links including one to my patreon if you
feel like supporting me that way if you
don't there's other links to check out
don't want to check those out that's
fine too because at the end of the day
folks you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]